Convierte las siguientes ecuaciones lineales en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen...
pendiente ordenada al origen,
y después gráficalas en el mismo plano cartesiano,
Y bueno sería bastante útil recordar
¿qué es la forma pendiente ordenada al origen?
y la forma pendiente ordenada el origen,
se ve más o menos así: "y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
donde "m" es la pendiente y "b" es la
ordenada al origen...
es decir, donde intersectamos al eje de las "y"
y por lo tanto, pues empecemos con la línea "a"
la línea "a" es "4x" más "2y" igual a -8
"4x" más "2y" igual a -8
y bueno lo que tengo que hacer es despejar a la "y"
por lo tanto lo primero que voy a hacer, es pasar este "4x" del otro lado de mi ecuación
y para eso, voy a restar "4x" de ambos lados de mi ecuación ¿y qué me va a quedar?
bueno del lado izquierdo esté "4x" y este "4x" se van
simple y sencillamente se cancelan y me queda "2y"
y del lado derecho me va a quedar -8 menos "4x" esto es lo mismo que "-4x" menos 8
lo voy a escribir así: "-4x" -8 ó -8 menos "4x" es
exactamente lo mismo
y bueno, ahora para despejar a "y" lo que me estorba es este 2 por lo tanto voy a dividir
ambos lados de mi ecuación entre 2
así que voy a dividir tanto el lado izquierdo como el lado derecho entre 2
¿y que me va a quedar?
aquí entre 2 y del lado derecho,
esté entre 2 y este entre 2
cada uno de los términos de mi lado
derecho los voy a dividir entre 2
y bueno 2 y 2 se van y me queda
que "y" es igual a -4 entre 2
lo cual es "-2x" menos 8 entre 2, lo cual es -4
-4
¡y ya está! ya tengo en la ecuación "a" visto como una recta de la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
y ya que tengo mi respuesta,
ahora lo que tengo que hacer es
graficarla en este plano cartesiano
y lo primero lo que me fijo es en la
ordenada al origen...
es decir, en donde intercectamos al eje de las "y"
e intersectamos el eje de las "y" en -4,
es decir justo aquí
aquí tengo mi primer punto que es el 0, -4 y a partir de aquí voy a graficar esta línea recta
porque tengo una pendiente de -2 ¿eso qué quiere decir? que cuando yo camino 1 horizontalmente
tengo que bajar 2 verticalmente,
cuando cambiamos en "x" 1 unidad cambiamos en "y" 2 unidades hacia abajo
una unidad, dos unidades hacia abajo y
tengo este punto.
O por ejemplo, si yo cambio 2 unidades
en "x" pues tendré que bajar 4 unidades en "y"
tengo este otro punto y de igual manera para cambios negativos en "x" cuando yo voy de manera horizontal...
pero hacia la izquierda
entonces tengo que subir 2 porque entonces me va a quedar, 2 positivo en "y" entre -1 en "x"
y tengo en la misma pendiente y de igual manera si cambio 2 negativos en "x"
tengo que subir 4 en "y"
y ya que tengo esto, entonces ahora déjame graficar esta línea recta y se va a ver más o menos así
es un trabajo decente para decir que esta es la gráfica de mi ecuación "a" o de mi recta "a"
y bueno, pues ahora vamos a
ver qué es lo que pasa con "b"
el inciso "b" dice "4x" es igual a -8
"4x" es igual a -8 y seguramente me vas a  decir...
¿y cómo puedo poner esto en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen?
yo no veo ningúna "y" y te voy a responder no es necesario tener a "y"
de hecho, esto lo podemos simplificar un poco dividiendo todo entre 4
y me va a quedar entre 4 entre 4, el 4 con el 4 se cancela,
y esto es lo mismo que "x" igual a -2
y esta es una recta constante, no importa cuánto valga "y", "x" siempre va a valer -2
entonces, si aquí está "x" igual a -2 no importa cuánto valga "y" "x" siempre va a valer -2.
Así que déjame graficarlo lo mejor posible
por aquí y para abajo también
"x" siempre va a valer -2
y bueno, claro, había olvidado que este es el eje de las "x" y este es el eje de las "y"
así que vamos a ver qué pasa con la línea "c"
la línea "c" ¿qué nos dice? 2 "y" es igual a -8
así que lo primero que voy a hacer es dividir ambos lados de esta igualdad entre 2
y me queda que "y", 2 y 2 se van, "y" es igual a -4
¿y qué crees?
ésta también es una recta constante
aquí nos está diciendo que "y" siempre
vale -4 pase lo que pase en "x"
valga lo que valga en "x" "y" siempre vale -4,
o dicho de otra manera, lo podemos ver
así "y" es igual a "0x" menos 4
entonces nuestra ordenada al origen sería -4,
que es justo éste mismo de aquí, éste de aquí es -4
y nuestra pendiente es de 0, es decir no cambia.
Si nosotros cambiamos 1 en "x" pues ya no cambia si nosotros tenemos 2 en "x" ya tampoco cambia
o cambia 0 unidades, por lo tanto nos mantenemos en esta línea recta que estoy dibujando justo aquí.
Es decir estamos fijándonos en la recta "y" es igual a -4 y el inciso "c".
¡Y perfecto lo hemos logrado!